Bud Light has a new ad out
I'm just going to catch you up really
quickly on the timeline Bud Light
sponsors puts them on a beer can
the the
Bud Light sales tank
people revolt against it
Bud Light doesn't apologize
but like sort of doubles down then Bud
Light blames it on some VP of marketing
and puts her on leave and I think maybe
fire is here I don't remember I think
she's probably gone
then Bud Light doubles down on it then
Bud Light makes a commercial about
horses then Bud Light still won't
apologize for the beer cam
is that sales continue to tank then Bud
Light begs people to buy their beer
again but I still want to apologize and
now
Bud Light has this commercial
a a true work of art a truly
completely ignorant wrong-headed work of
art on why you should buy Bud Light
again
[Music]
there we go it's a older white guy
rubbing Bud Light on his face
[Music]
people fall in a Bud Light keg
that keeps dropping what a bunch of
goofy dumb stupid pick idiot room Bud
Light drinkers I keep stumbling and
falling
[Music]
now it's kind of windy oh look at this
dummy he can't even get to a hammock
[Music]
stupid Bud Light drinkers
there we go we got more
[Music]
middle-aged white guys
I don't know I don't know what the
commercial is trying to tell you other
than
middle-aged white guys
and kind of fratty looking guys the two
main constituencies for Bud Light
uh they're just a bunch of stupid klutzy
idiots now buy our beard dummies
and they it started out with that VP of
marketing saying we hate how we've got
this kind of fratty you know Vibe of of
Bud Light we just hate we want to switch
it so we want to embrace the cultured
beautiful serious sophisticated
people and then the actual audience for
Bud Light went away they said all right
you sloppy filthy deplorables whatever
here let's let here's a couple pictures
you stumbling around because you don't
even know how to put two feet in front
of you yeah okay drink it up drink up
our slop you're gonna buy it yet no
that's probably not gonna work not very
effective even if they're just trying to
return to normal and say hey Bud Light
is just what you drink at a party it's
easy to drink please buy or drink again
here's what I have to say
until Bud Light
tweets out my CPAC speech the
eradication speech in its entirety with
three thumbs up emojis the boycott
continues
I hereby decree
and I think you will see that reflected
in the market cap okay
if you liked the sound of that you are
going to love the taste of magic spoon
even more with magic spoon you can say
goodbye to Bland sugary cereals and
experience breakfast like never before
packed with high quality ingredients and
flavors that you already know and love
like cocoa fruity frosted and peanut
butter which is very very tasty magic
spoon will take your breakfast game to
new heights my producer Ben Davies can't
stop talking about how much he loves
magic spoons peanut butter cereal
to which I say hey you jerk stop
stealing the peanut butter cereal from
the office and let me have it instead
but he loves it he really likes it so I
figure I'll throw the guy a bone he can
have the box of peanut butter I'll save
myself for the other magic spoon cereals
have zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and are only 140 calories per
serving they're also gluten-free grain
free and soy free experience the magic
of magic spoon cereals by visiting
magicspoon.com Knolls and get five bucks
off your order Magic spoon is so
confident in their product they back it
with a 100 happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason they will
refund your money what are you waiting
for click the link below or head over to
magicspoon.com Knowles to grab a variety
pack try it today magicspoon.com for
five bucks off your order
unelectability
that's what this campaign's about
Trump is running on the Trump campaign
DeSantis is also running in the Trump
Lane
you've got a bunch more moderate
candidates or candidates running a
campaign like it's 2008 and it's not
they're not going anywhere there are
still some candidates coming out of left
field but if you look at the poll
numbers it's Trump versus DeSantis they
both have the same campaign platform so
the campaign is about electability who
can win and then wield power and there's
a new poll that just came out from
Emerson College which
I think shakes up some of the
conventional wisdom on this
conventional wisdom right now is
DeSantis has a much better shot at being
elected than Donald Trump maybe that's
true maybe with polls you know a polls
and a buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee but according to this poll
both DeSantis and Trump lose to Joe
Biden
and according to this poll actually
according to this poll Trump does better
than DeSantis against Biden according to
Emerson 44 would vote for Biden 43
percent would vote for Trump
and 43 percent would vote for Biden
versus DeSantis and only 37 percent
would vote for DeSantis
but here's where it gets kind of weird
if Cornell West the leftist populist
candidate is in the race on Election Day
then
only in that circumstance does the
Republican win
Trump 41 Biden 40 Cornell West six
percent
you know me I am the most skeptical of
polls and statistics broadly as anybody
gets but especially this far out
especially National polls but this is
really interesting not because of what
it says about Trump and DeSantis not
even really what it says about those
guys versus Joe Biden it's the Cornell
West thing Cornell West pulls votes not
from Trump but from Biden
Cornell West has something in common
with both Trump and Biden which is that
he's a leftist so he has something in
common with Biden but he's a populist so
he has something in common with Trump
and what we see here is that when a
leftist populist gets in the race he
pulls from the leftist candidate
which would help the right-wing populist
candidate
and which tells you that there is lots
of room for a populist movement to grow
in 2016 there were a lot of Voters who
came out and said I've never voted
before or I've always been you know
maybe a Democrat but now I'm voting for
Trump
the phenomenon of the Trump Democrats
just like you said the Reagan democrats
back in 1980.
some people think well there's just a
ceiling on the support that Trump can
get there's a ceiling on the support
that a populist candidate can get
this poll suggests that's not true I
think there's a lot of room for a
populist candidate to grow now maybe
Trump's got his supporters and there's
not a ton of room for for that to grow
unless Joe Biden completely craters
which is a totally plausible scenario
but
in terms of populism generally cracking
up the sort of uniparty Monopoly and the
stale old talking points and the stale
of priorities of both parties there's a
ton of room it would seem to grow you'd
grab five percent from the libs
immediately and if you had a candidate
who was better than Cornell West you
could probably grab a lot more
than that if you think that populism is
over or on the decline as I think a lot
of establishment Republicans are hoping
is the case I think a lot of
establishment Republicans frankly are
hoping that if Trump gets a nomination
in in 2024 that he loses and then the
GOP can finally reset to the good old
Happy Days of Mitt Romney and I don't
know ASA Hutchinson and all these
squishes and they can become Democrat
light again
I don't think that's going to happen I
don't think that's what the numbers show
boy what a great clip that was make sure
that you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time